et bleu bonsoir le vin soit voilà vous
êtes on va passer une petite trentaine
de minutes en live avec ses amis ici
présents carlito mcfly lucioles et le
nahd du mini vous regarder la
rediffusion
ça arrive même aux jours meilleurs et
tongres a essayé d'invoquer des esprits
on va s'y rendent tout de suite j'ai mis
les marais du coup un petit un petit
endroit pour faire pour essayer un wii
via en toute cordialité
oui qu'est-ce que tu regardé cet endroit
magnifique
voilà alors je vais essayer de up les
amis sur un certain cachet de compenser
vous ça vous plaît même temps alors j'ai
écrasé les bougies c'est un truc qui
bouge tout seul à ses petites maps light
que tu te positionnes ici présents à
dubaï sur les côtés de terre pas du tout
absolument pas mais mes toiles à lui
sollicité masse outre vous voulez que
j'ai celle ci faisait pas oui ça arrive
plus que je peux manger alors je vous
laisse découvrir
je vous laisse découvrir le ouija donc
cette boîte donc du coup de 1972 mais
ont été achetés sur le bon coin et
préalablement achetés à new york dans
une brocante
je vous laisse découvrir un peu précisé
que c'est pour 8 et plus oui est ce que
ça vous plaît c'est bon c'est pas mal de
faire rire vos nerfs ce qui a déjà joué
obligea ici je n'ai alors moi je n'ai
jamais jamais joué de ma vie je vais le
mettre sur un petit chemin mais jamais
alors c'est vrai que non il a raison
mcfly ouija c'est un anagramme de à
jouer comme je crois ou non c'est la
validation en français et en allemand
est ce que quelqu'un a déjà joué à ce
truc sagim entendu parler quoi l'idc
d'invoquer quand même des esprits j'ai
jamais fait ça de ma vie c'est très
content de participer à vous avez déjà
j'étais un peu genre bizarre gérante un
médium et où donc du coup je crois grave
en ce genre de truc parce que tu as
rencontré un médium bas parce qu'il m'a
déjà présent dans la vie je suis médium
non mais c'est tout devient beaucoup
plus et leur confiance quoi j'ai foncé
il paraît qu'il faut alors lucioles à
torcher quand je lui ai dit tu viens
elle m'a dit j'ai le mal à envoyer des
textes pour toute la nuit encore cible
pas stressé je mets juste pensé bien se
renseigner avant
maintenant je me retrouve seul à la
bibliothèque j'ai fais pas je vous dis
médias le fait que je suis allé sur la
science obscur points comme je vais
faire un cartable
je me suis renseigné de ouf
je connais un petit peu alors j'ai
décidé tout ce que vous avez découvert
ce live via les réseaux sociaux
j'ai annoncé du coup ce live j'ai eu
beaucoup de tweets fauquet notamment un
certain marc gabriel qui est parti en
vrille mais bon bref on va pas citer non
donné une bise au marais on a eu des ne
fait absolument que ça on a eu 2 mais
vous êtes fou ce que j'ai préféré c'est
non je ne regarderai pas parce que ça va
la malédiction va passer par internet et
toucher des millions mais la malédiction
a une super votre connexion quel est le
risque
je ne sais pas on va découvrir les gens
le disent attention vers la durée parce
que on va à broc et l'esprit et
peut-être si on le fait mal ça va nous
suivre longtemps voilà c'est ça l'esprit
est resté avec elle je n'ai aucune info
bah on va essayer de d'appeler un esprit
il va peut être très bon et voilà on va
essayer de il faut dire la fin au revoir
oui il faut dire au revoir absolument
on reçoit de sept premiers pas derrière
la boîte du monde à lui seul
non mais c'est pour les 8 ans et plus
c'est que fait avorter
ici on les des notices ok mais là c'est
du déjà parlé c'est une question à la
fois on ne va pas bien se parler en même
temps on fait très mal selon lui
mieux que ça en anglais ça fait chier ok
mais il disait sur tous les sites
un mystère points comme la première
règle c'était de faire sérieusement
ok on va faire ça va avec déjà ce que
c'est que ce soit clair
moi j'ai pas trop d'affinités avec ce
genre de procédés donc j'ai envie de le
faire sérieusement il faut voir ce qui
se passe puisque on commencerait par
vous attendre peut-être et à des jeux
passe avec un mode absolument incroyable
les attentes de carlito s'il te plaît
est ce que tu penses qu'on va invoquer
un esprit ce soir déjà le mec j'ai
toujours pas compris un esprit d esprit
l'esprit de je ne sais pas on sait pas
on peut invoquer l'esprit de kurt cobain
par exemple l'hôtel c'est pas faisons le
directement bah oui alors lola tu as
vivant tu y crois énormément puisque tu
as rencontré un médium un jour j'y crois
pas non mais je crois aux esprits tout
ça mais voilà mes juges je sais moi j'y
crois pas trop à ça je crois pas trop à
ce jeu là haut j'ai dit d'accord mais je
veux faire ça il faut savoir qu'on est
au youtube space
oui d'accord et que c'est un vieil
immeuble parisien et non mais c'est vrai
si à la limite si l ennemi ton était au
milieu de la forêt et que c'était juste
un nouveau bâtiment je sais pas si ça
joue tu vois volume sur l'express que ça
joue ou pas passer tous du coup alors en
gros le ouija qu'ils apparu dans les
années
je ne sais pas dégustation je voulais
bien faire à ce critère pour qu'on aille
faute une note d information qui les
retient j'expliquais une secrétaire qui
ne participe pas et qui retient toutes
les infos et qui note et la basse et
très lâche de tapas remercia la croix
est ce que je crois que toi tu as une
sensibilité avec le spiritisme et
l'ésotérisme
oui tout à fait j'ai vraiment ça en moi
j'aime bien je connais j'y crois fort
mais après le jeu je pense à des trucs
ses patients à qui connaissent un peu le
pendule voyez c'est un peu ce genre de
truc ça peut marcher juste avec nos
énergies
c'est très en fait ça peut être la coupe
eh ben je propose qu'on commence de ce
pas si vous avez des questions à poser
du coup cet esprit n'hésitez pas à dire
dans les commentaires ou essaiera de les
poser pour total voilà c'est aussi dans
les accords on essaie de dire ah ouais
dans le monde on demande un des genres
kurt cobain ou monde il y en a un qu'il
est je pense sont ces paquets on ne sait
pas qui c'est ça dépend des rtt s.koné
moment il ya des esprits qui sont
disposés maison il ya anglais ce qu'il
ya un traducteur
ces mecs là google de question qu'il y
ait remplacé bon trans la transmettent
alors moi je vais noté son message un
commentaire
tout ce qui se passe pour toi tu fais la
secrétaire c'est ça oui mais tu
participes manger toujours assiégés par
ailleurs oui bien sûr poser les
questions qu'il faut poser le dow a
légèrement dessus le toit de calme oui
alex silva l'électrique la main gauche
du capital est un droit que je crois
qu'on sanctionne il méconnaît mettons
cela mais j'ai pas vu de réglettes si on
veut un maximum de commentaires sur le
nom des doigts de la main alors c'est
bon tout le monde et son de son petit
doigt dessus et papier trop fort alors
et puis la première question me semble
trompés et trompé moi si tu peux me
tromper mois ci le bar est plus à l'aise
en perdition ses esprits et sa pièce à
la pause et je vais là je vais imposer
par la chaîne donc quand la machine à
jouer esprit es tu là c'était la fin de
cette vidéo merci
venez faire ça vous aura plu est ce que
peut-être il faut poser différemment la
question monsieur s'effrite hier fut
donnée attendait ça bouge légèrement
ça bouge légèrement vers le nom pourquoi
il ya un oui et non c'est moi
hi ha oui sinon les mange le cache
depuis le 19 mai jeu
jeu mais si je le fais l'intense voyez
on les dit deux ensembles n'ont suffi
non esprit rei es-tu là
ça ça bouge légèrement et c'est sur le g
c'est cool man 3 4 ans
c'est quelqu'un qui a alors esprit est
ce que tu peux nous répondre clairement
à plus ou moins fortes
est ce que tu peux ne répond plus
clairement sur le fait que tu es là ou
non pas si tu réponds non c'est à dire
que tu es la rict unis tombent enfin
est ce qu'on dirait pas tous ensemble
esprit es tu là esprit es tu là
voilà
pour l'instant c'est globalement tendu
j'ai presque eu ces trois mois de ce qui
les attend est ce qu'il faut commencer
un endroit précis du plateau genre sur
louis où tu vois pas ce que j'ai envie
peut-être un goûter je revote au reboot
gym était vraiment un jeu sans que
personne ne connaît j'avoue j'ai acheté
le jeu sur le bon coin et déjà beaucoup
mais accessoirement il est probablement
nous dit pas ce qu'il y avait deux
personnes qui veulent s'en débarrasser
je vous avoue que j'ai donc je pense que
aller ont à peine après le 0-1
ok les voir l'équipe 0 plaisir réagi au
mot plaisir mais les chauves-souris qui
bouge tout seul vous le voyez au palace
ou crise servira pas j'ai regardé s'il
voit la chauve souris
je sais pas il a eu deux points noirs de
points rouges dans l'obscurité
est-ce que vous ayez la chauve-souris ok
c'est un moment pas hyper important on
va poser la question un parent à la
question sinon il comprend pas d'accord
dakar 12 sept
ok ok j'ai une haine des chips que j'ai
mangé de permettre il semble que comme
goethe est une des raisons pour laquelle
l'esprit les parties de poker esprit es
tu là
tout petit salé ya des gens c'est une
chauve souris
bon alors est ce que vous voyez ce qui
se passe des choses que tu as vu le
réflexe q92 regarde le révulse et souk
souris bref là ils regardent le réflexe
du 9-2 je suis à collectionner cardiaque
cardiac les plaisirs des toits après
quelle idée d'avoir des salaires aussi
quoi bon attendez on va lire un petit
commentaire
qu'est ce que vous en pensez alors on se
place quand vous avez commencé à jouer
surtout que j'étais une à prendre un jeu
un peu plus le réflexe du 9-2 ça
commence
donne-moi l'auto excusez-moi ya ton père
l'adjoint est ce qu'on peut lui en
[ __ ] une étude si tu peux le faire
maintenant
non pas avec des ressources aux marchés
sur les people
c'était même esprit es tu là le ciel
n'est pas bien elle regarde celui là
arrive bien manger au nazisme et vous
coule c'est une autre homme décroche
expliqué écoutez moi il ya peut-être des
esprits conneries ça va mal et il a
commencé à parler j'en prendrais un
monde de scratch qui se décroche l
appareil et après qu'il est tombé
d'accord c'est ça c'est décrocher alors
je suis vraiment navré à temps mais qui
a dit et nous a remis dans le noir aux
citoyens un truc chelou
j'avais l'idée du noir je les ai vus
dans un film et je peux pas le dire mais
je me suis un peu inspiré d'accord tout
le monde le faisait deux jours et ça et
je me suis dit que monsieur après j'ai
un peu craqué je vois la pression j'ai
sauté sur la table et si on fait un
petit débrief de ce qui s'est passé je
me permets que j'ai tant qu'on a demandé
esprit es-tu là et il ya vraiment la
chanson remixée décroche oui maintenant
donc sachez que réussi chacun à son
analyse mais il ya clairement une
relation de cause à effet entre nos
questions est ce qui fait qu'on va
vraiment le hasard on réessaie du coup
de poser cette question
hashtags ali pou y est doublé alors moi
les gars monsieur place je veux faire ma
tétouan non c'est très mal poli je suis
toujours là écoutez moi david écoutez
moi sur rien et n'écoute pas qu'on peut
légitimement se poser la question du
rôle de soutien dans cette organisation
ce qui nous a tendu un piège
[Musique]
alors je quitte le 4g obligé puisque tu
me dire du salariat
j'ai oublié de vous dire c'est que ça
réagit au bruit sur cette école était
besoin parce que sur les tailles va
s'allumer et l'on est touché aux caisses
il faut alors comme maintenant on est
avait un silence total aura reposé la
question est alors les internautes
veulent savoir est ce que l'esprit est
là on attend le pardon au map les amplis
comme ça que je réagis comme on accorder
d'accords savons plus qui je suis on est
centrée n'a pas d'accord souscrivez à un
abonnement
nous pouvons ce qui doit permettre cette
fois-ci mets ton doigt car c'est une
puce wi a une poule à a
c'est bien générer quelque chose à dire
les filles concertation arrêter de
regarder dans le site a mis en scène
quelque chose avec quelqu'un oui et
c'est quelqu'un se prend une droite par
carlitos
alors là c'est aussi le bon élève
d'issue mais il n'y a absolument pas de
personne qui va se manifester que ce
soit parfait donc donc ça fait un peu
mal à l'aise et non à la question
nerveusement ça de mini croyait qu'il
n'y crois pas non mais ballon ne soit
pas une théorie je crois juste au
scratch voilà une strate chine
sinon il vous faut ce ton iphone point
qu'il sur la table a dit comprendre la
casse les ondes de les ça marche
alors tu sembles barbecue je me donnais
mon avis j'ai mangé des films jeux sans
suite mais ça va partir en plus je vais
vous raconter un truc c'est empirique
chez moi c'est à dire tu me connais toi
l'esprit achètent et libération gags et
positionne copé
je préfère le même humour est arrêté qui
vous fait déclenchement j'avais une
femme dirige plus la prononcer journée
dans la censure série à la fois déjà la
loi est bâtie sur celle là non c'est que
moi pour moi c'est empirix est vraiment
j'aimerais le voir pour le croire et à
gérer mais par contre je suis très
ouvert je me demande que ça je peux
poser la question et soit six de plus
ses esprits et heures je pense voilà
voilà
on essaye esprits et huila c'est toi qui
le suivrait personnes situées sous le
doigt ça marche plus c'est bien jeter
jonquière non je te jure j'ai dirigé pas
bouger les partis d'ailleurs qui mais
cela c'est toi j'ai un problème de
tachycardie donc quoi qui a fait quoi
bon je suis perdu on recommence qui
qu'est ce que ça doit indiquer pourquoi
il appelle dans ses rangs le rond luron
la central valley année verrouillait
sous le no on est en train d'arriver
maintenant commencé à sonder les filles
la caméra est là bas aussi un peu de
respect pour nos spectateurs oui je vous
aime bien qu'on avait qui peuvent
souscrire un abonnement vais je vais on
va peut-être que les internautes vont
pouvoir nous aider un petit peu l'esprit
ci se sont moqués mais on s'excuse
vraiment très important alors taper paye
à savoir nra avec alors attendez après
peut-être c'est l'esprit dit müller aut
quelqu'un se moquer lui ne sera pas
assez mais attends je pète devant ma
fille je veux dire je respecte ma fille
tu vois c'est pas une question de
respect alors tu peux reposer à quelque
peuple et moi je la mode
esprit es tu là
vos paris
oui mais franchement est ce que ça
est-ce que ça bouchonne moi c'est pour
moi ça bouge pas alors ça va bouger un
petit peu de tout ça c'est vrai sg c'est
la question
non mais là c'est toi c'est toi que
c'est toi faut pas qu'elle bougeait oui
c'était en regardant ma tête non merci
je regarde ma tête il fait non avec
l'attak merci tu peux le dire avec la
voix [ __ ] mais là tu as c'est eux qui
fait attendre ça bouge je vous ai sa
boulette que est-ce que j'ai une
question à poser est ce qu'on doit être
pur ou un pur avec à les esprits et s'il
te plaît montre nous que tu es là de
façon claire et précise par le wii ou
sans te commande est manifeste toi il
est vrai que il y à cette tête d'alien
[Musique]
oui j'ai peut-être nantis mais par
contre vraiment la goutte s'est
transformé en iphone tu es super curieux
[Musique]
non non il a su à temps est ce que t'as
pas jurer regarde la trappe et son vol
je le jure ça lui revient dessus c'est
vraiment la blague la plus basique du
monde à le jette à vatan le plus gros
bien sûr elle a clairement quelqu'un
dans le coup tu peux pas déclenchée on
me dit ici le démon s'appelle zozos
arrêtez tout de suite c'est pas fake oui
ç'a changé dit il faut le faire
sérieusement ce dossier même mais ce que
me dit les internautes art je me permet
de nourrir un peu ne lui parle pas de sa
mort ça sert à rien l'esprit va pas vous
vous écoutez donc d'accord le mec qui
sait qu'il a fait graver peur [ __ ]
mettez vos deux doigts mais non mais
quoi vous attendez-vous les jeux en
ligne à la goutte à tomber nos trucs le
truc à nous par lui c'est le truc n'est
pas sous vos pieds c'est très fine la
wii qui attendait sur play avec des
jetons je vous jure que cet iphone
jeunes du tube space j'ai juste mis une
voiture téléguidée qui avance et je fais
un truc qui se rajoutent nice et jean et
thriller qui va tomber
comme la parade de disneyland paris bien
sûr et 10 10 esprit esprit es tu là avec
deux doigts
donc il faut mettre les deux doyens pas
de doute c'est un concept ans il a très
bien je la sens bien ça on tente météo
de la world et barnes à il ne faut pas
enlever vaudois ne pas même celle
atteint avec les coudes
ah bon ça faut pas mettre des coups
alors on réessaie sociale tu peux poser
la question alors lucio est alors entré
là vraiment je me suis posé la question
on te plaît non elle y croit passé mais
sylvie gilbaut dollars il n'y a pas du
tout esprit es tu là
c'est ce à quoi tu pour rien le métier
doit pas titan rester devant ça s'arrête
un yalta faire là dessus le premier
support de france des réflexes de haut
sont alors bien le bon élève il ya que
garnier qui a laissé les doigts c'était
dans le rif
j'avoue on fit arrêter d'aller
directement enlève les coudes on lève
les coudes les parents auront l'esprit
des téléspectateurs
attendez là ça c'est à bouger énormément
on est sur le terrain avoue penser qu'
il est là et que c'est la lettre c'est
vrai c'est robespierre mais qui est là
c'était donc c'est vraiment bas attendez
excusez moi je blague faut je le redis
ça marche avec toi tu sais comme aretha
franklin
mon corps et mon esprit es tu là
bon les gars à sabou citant des traders
mais s'interroger mais il est sur le
live en même temps soyez indulgents non
mais il faut prier non non et non
mais hier les gars je te jure r&d
raymond devos
arrête un moment d'émotion nous pencher
tout ça non plus j'ai pensé raymond
devos et fait nos jeux de mots racontent
des blagues
raymond c'est sûr j'ai eu un fils ont
les moyens est-ce que ça s'est dirigé
vers le yes ou pas oui clairement
c'est ça qui compte ou c'est ce qui a
dans la bouche qui a dans la bulle est à
la fois la dernière réponse du monde
normal à écoute c'est fatigant garder la
même année mairie film pas pendant tout
le film par nature ne vais pas vous
n'êtes pas bien les pros qui voudra
parler qu'à merci pas de souci c'est
sympa est ce que non mais qu est ce qu
on a une deuxième est ce que on avait
peut-être poser nos questions
ah si tu nous as deviné est ce qu'il est
bien ou pas bien cet espace à un bonus
primes ont annoncé l'arrivée ça signifie
quelque chose
fb oui ingénieurs le mec moi oui peut
mentir l'esprit est ce que tu manges non
mais arrêtez qui bouge je suis pas bien
que non j'ai pas mon coup tu rajoutes
sur la vie de mes fait jouer ses
arguments mais c'est là aucun sens si
dirais oui
don king membre des jeux de cartes et
qui voulait dire rester un maximum cette
vidéo c'est que je me posais une
question a à l'esprit les doigts les
esprits
est-ce que tu apprécies les vidéos de
may cry carlito
un public que de ça c'est des gens qui
se marre là alors il faut pas selon leur
beauté est ce que on ne demanderait pas
si c'est un bon ou un mauvais estriens
vas-y mécènes qui les faisait qu'il faut
la poser comment on dirait regarde on
dirait une ivrogne dans un bar de sainte
est très amateur
allez c'est pas si mal après six manches
c'est ce qu'a ce mois ci analyse d'un
tiers par contre lorient c'est sûr côté
ses intérêts on dirait la gare de
lorient mais c'est ce que vous avez déjà
mais la gare de lorient s'cusez moi que
l'esprit n'est pas évident monsieur ne
peut poser la question si c'est un bon
ou mauvais esprit on regarde nos rangs
de ce côté des prix jamais vu des gens
autant radeau de beinheim tu vois ok
esprits donc il va nous dire sur wii non
et je vais vous dire oui et non ok
esprit es-tu un gentil esprits
cela donnerait mine du côté les esprits
je touche à touche pas du tout je suis
ici je suis ambitieux tanit
il va vers le oui qui va il a
tranquillement vers le oui ça c'est vrai
excusez moi j'aime regarder personne ne
te pousse ce truc c'est vrai ça bouge
tout seul c'est plus à wickham en avant
sont menacés - est-ce que tu es gentil
mais parfois tu as fait une crasse à ton
petit frère par exemple une fois vas-y
c'est bon tout pas les esprits explique
300 il a dit qu'il était gentil phase i
en général oui
après ce qui est pas mal et série est ce
qu'on te dérange esprits est ce que l'on
te dérange
il va tout en valorisant le fichier dans
la personne personne ne voulait y est on
est un truc de ouf
après personne ne touche le truc est en
pente vers le oui en même temps c'est
vrai handicap
donc on le dérangerait les gentils en
fait chier c'est vraiment ignoble
échantillons dont le nom qu'on a
d'autres questions peut-être aller poser
c'est rien c'est vraiment une série le
thé les banques elles-mêmes
c'est une nouvelle chaîne youtube au
taux plein je vais me mettre une capote
madame tous les chypriotes et légendes
et c'est dur il vous plaît laissez-nous
vous laissez pas la goutte se déplacer
totalement ça sert à rien d'enchaîner
question d'accord charlie charlie a eu à
coeur non non non non non sûrement pas
mais ça sent le voyage
arrêtez de crier déjà le terrain très
bien on à bercy
l'it bonjour à baisser mais qu'on oublie
pas tu vas nous l'avait très bien dit on
a besoin sinon il n'a pas dit bonjour
c'est vrai vous devez rester sérieux
aussi sinon il y aura jamais rien là et
c'est vrai qu'on est passé
la goutte soyez sérieux s'il vous plaît
il est gentil mais on le fait lol ptdr
ya ya vraiment quelqu'un dans le couloir
non y'a personne s'il y a 6 6 1
il ya un mec là bas dans le fond tout en
le fond il garde il ya un garde du corps
pour nous sauver mais je crois c'est pas
un esprit du tout c'est un métier ah oui
et n'oublie pas surtout de ne pas de
faux pas envie de dire au revoir
oui je fais y en avait six ans avant
même temps le en anglais arrêté
d'enlever vaudois demandé son nom
battant mais si déjà le oui et le non
c'est compliqué je vais à la messe et
moi j'adore
vous n'arriverez jamais vaudois avec les
délais que c'est vraiment ce qui revient
une traîtresse en qui je me souviens
qu'à partir de maintenant je crois pas
les avaient enlevés à plusieurs reprises
alors soyons concentrés cyprien vas-y
c'est ta chaine un bon jour pas de
réponse oui ça arrive plein d'excusés
mon bonjour et fraîche bonjour esprits
esprit es tu là
gt1 mais ils se déplacent toujours à
louis est ce que ça pourrait aller vers
le haut la luciole tu montes bien
personne personne ce que je suis appuyé
non mais faut pas enlever 10 trucs vous
enlevez pas des doigts mais laissez les
genres et flore est ok mais des gars
avec sip
je t'attends lever la pinte formation
les spacieux bien n'enlève pas et reste
on focus est comprendre s'il veut un
problème au niveau des doigts sur la
goûte bon qu'ensuite il a pas il a pas
tort je suis témoin les commentaires des
gens
et qu'est ce qu'on devrait faire après
s'il vous plaît ils disent qu'ils aient
déjà qu'il faut mettre les doigts de la
main gauche
adam hunger je l'avais dit mains du club
bon c'est pas mal de savoir
quand ce n'est pas les coudes pas les
garçons jouent enfin un jour bonjour
bonjour esprit esprit es tu là aucun
moyen de l'appui les bulles mais la la
la la la la la la suite des événements
c'est là on est sur quelque chose à ces
questions là on est concentré à temps
enfin ça y est
luciole la suite des événements est ce
que tu es japon jouera donc voulu rester
gros jour bonjour bonjour à chaque début
de phrase c'est bonjour bonjour une
falaise il faut lui demander si nous
aime bien
et bonjour esprits est ce que tu nous
aimes bien c'est bien rires on est comme
des qualités c'est ça est ce que
laissait un bannissement
est-ce que tu as un bon esprit non non
non non non mais sérieux non je ne fais
rien je vous le jure je vous ai personne
ne fait rien c'est pas possible il va
pas vers le nom je vous le jure sur tout
l'est encore revenir en arrière
ah oui j'aurais n'hésite charge des
codes du film du film leïla actuellement
tu pourrais nommer les remèdes ne
tournait pas ses prix d'amis dé prendre
partout ils sont méchants mais bon
confie je gérerai les trouve dans le vé
les doigts mais sans rien sans fernard
esprits enfin les écouter abbas au
revoir et aux petits breaks petit break
le même constamment de la même chose d
unique du 9 2 tab alors j'aimerais juste
qu'on puisse débriefer de cet état
d'esprit on va esprits
apparemment il ya une coupure les gars
il ya eu un petit une petite coupure
peut-être l'esprit qui a qui nous a fait
ça du coup je me permets de faire leur
petit débrief je viens de passer une
demi heure ensemble assez d esprit a par
erreur ok des esprits et la seule chose
qu'on a invoqué de sûr c'est un monsieur
qui travaillent ici
le mec bots you tube space et l'esprit à
compter de like donc l'esprit et de
l'est qu'est ce que ça vous a fait une
petite expérience croissante métier
dissiper vous aviez ont rien
d'incroyable
si tu avais pas mis les blagues partout
moi je serai pas le chien quand on s'est
concentré c'est important de le dire
pour quelqu'un qui ne croient pas quand
moi quand assez concentré avec les deux
doigts et qu'on rigolait ouais ouais
c'était assez découvre parce que on le
voyait bien quand on avait froid et
cyprien d'aller en vol et demi le truc
oui j'avoue j'ai placé des petites de
petits trucs notamment cette tête
d'alien sur une voiture téléguidée et
cette chauve-souris accroché et nous
avons derrière popeye qui a juste appuyé
sur avant et qui a descendu le truc
c'est tout ce qu'il a fait de la soirée
derrière ce rideau est en tout cas moi
j'ai apprécié partager ce moment ça pas
moi je faisais un peu de données se
tarissent et j'étais content de partager
avec vous t'as pas trop traumatisés
ça va ou non ça ne soit pas je me tourne
vers vous parce que clairement non mais
ça va bastonner dit au revoir esprit
jouer voilà opération mais moi c'est
vrai si vous voulez faire une expérience
aussi cool à la maison vous prenez un
pendule vous achetez va produire et nous
sommes même un truc comme ça que vous
avez l'habitude autour du cou et vous
pensez vous donner juste un petit moment
au début vous laissez ensuite et mails
entre les oui riche vous pensez oui il
va tourner dans le sens des aiguilles du
monde vous pensé non et va trôner dans
le sens ça n'a rien à voir ses
explications rationnelles
non c'est pas ça rassure ça lui a donné
un peu pas beaucoup non fumeurs me le
faire un peu plus
merci beaucoup merci à vous mes chers
amis chers guez dont les coûts luciole
le la du benny mc fly cailleteau les ont
chacun six personnes là des chaînes
respectives
will you tube et vous impliquer dans la
description et moi je vous dis à très
vite sur l'outil internet aux mélodies
fameux jeu court qui paiera pour
terminer ces bons sets ça marchait bien
non c'est m